it's PS plus extra and premium time once
again the mid-month update to the gaming
catalog that heaps on more games for you
to play I'm Adam hello there and I'll
take you through all 17 of them and
there's 10 leaving two there's a lot to
get through so let's crack on Cana
Bridge of spirits is the headlining game
of the month a Simply Beautiful
action-adventure title from Ember Labs a
studio that was renowned for making
Zelda animations and that influence has
most definitely been instilled into the
game Kana lives in a world where Spirits
are stuck here until their Affairs are
complete so Cana is a spirit guide the
world is essentially a puzzle platformer
with tons of melee and archery Combat on
top of that are these creatures the rot
tiny little beings that Kana can control
and Order around both in battle and to
solve puzzles the running time is about
10 hours in length and it's on both PS4
and PS5 and the best thing of all you
can unlock hats for your creature is
cute little boogers if you need
something more aggressive by all means
you should give Doom Eternal a try your
job is to slay all the minions of hell
that dare to even think about invading
Earth Doom Eternal takes the fast-paced
first-person shooter got Fest into
overdrive with a growing arsenal of
weapons from flamethrowers to rocket
launchers from plasma rifles to The BFG
9000. Doom Eternal is a blood path the
soundtrack in Doom Eternal is amazing
and as the difficulty ramps up in game
so does the music speaking of difficulty
each enemy is weak to a certain weapon
in Your Arsenal and in a mere few hours
you'll be switching arms on the fly to
tactically win fights it's not just run
and Gun anymore there's actually a
pretty decent story here too to get your
teeth into set in 2163 after demons have
already annihilated 60 of the world's
population there's only one guy who can
save the rest game three is Rider's
Republic again on both PS4 and PS5 the
massively multiplayer online playground
lets us ride a BMX snowboard and ski
down the mountain and wing suit from the
top of glaciers extreme sports in an
open sandbox packed with multiplayer
races and game modes with 64 players on
PS5 taking part all over the world
although when I tried this on PS4 the
limit was 20 players if posting High
trick scars is your Forte there's a mode
for that if perilously Wing suiting
through Crags in a cliff face is your
jam there's a mode for that too and
there's also standard Racing for boring
people like me Riders Republic is all
about community so try jumping with
friends if you can to truly get a feel
for what this game could be have you
seen slay the Spire we've had this this
year on PS plus essential already and
like I said back then the gameplay is
way better than what it looks like on
the screen right now a card based
roguelike let me explain we are tasked
with climbing up a Spire by fighting
enemy selecting cards to do that Cards
win battles simple enough right each
Victory expands Our Deck and shapes it
for the next fight as things ramp up
your card Synergy is imperative I really
struggle to explain how good this game
is so maybe you should just try it right
or not you do you
foreign this month's horror game is the
survival thrill Fest The Evil Within on
the PS4 from the creator of Resident
Evil 4 comes another single player story
focused fear-inducing game played in
third person we must scavenge for
supplies and decide when's the right
time to stand and fight or run for your
life it really is the lack of resources
in this game that makes it so
successfully build anxiety within you oh
and where does it all begin in a mental
hospital yay get ready to fight inmate
to subconsciously created monsters The
Evil Within blend reality and dreams
into one realm and it's not for the
faint-hearted horror fans Rejoice we
have two Wolfenstein games on PS plus
extra this month the alternate history
first person shooter where World War II
was won by the other guys Wolfenstein
the old blood has us playing as BJ
blaskovich armed to the teeth with
specific weapons from the 1940s as well
as some more futuristic guns that would
still look out of place in 2023 we are
Behind Enemy Lines and must stop the guy
with the dash that YouTube doesn't like
me to name on the other hand there is
Wolfenstein 2 The New Colossus this one
brings technology in that can resurrect
Fallen Soldiers by this time though
America has been overrun by Germany so
it's time for BJ to inspire the second
American Revolution I have no idea who
the first one was against The New
Colossus has more refined cover shooting
mechanics and Scopes and other weapon
attachments too Wolfenstein 2 has
reviews in the high 90s definitely want
to try
hey what about a real Thrill Ride people
Bassmaster Fishing okay I'll be honest
I've never played this so here's the
blurb instead compete against 10 Pro
Anglers across eight Real World
locations and climb to the top of the
fishing rankings obtaining sponsorships
as you go one day you will be the best
of the best if you've played this could
you leave a message in the comments
below and tell us should we try it or
not do we need to be the Bassmaster
Paradise killer is next on both PS4 and
PS5 and it takes us to this sunny little
island to relax but not so fast as a
murder has happened here we are
officially in a murder mystery game
become a detective and sleuth your way
to the answers collecting evidence to
uncover the killer Paradise killer has
reviews of 9 out of 10 making it one of
the highest ranked games this month and
it takes about 12 hours to complete so
will you try it Monster boy and the
cursed Kingdom on both PS4 and PS5 is
next and it's a platformer originally
made for the Nintendo switch the
gameplay is akin to the old say bigger
games of the early 1990s a linear side
scroller with hidden extras to uncover
and it takes about 18 hours to complete
it all a surprise bonus game came to the
catalog for extra and premium tiers of
PlayStation Plus last week and a dine a
top-down old school Adventure game with
lots of similarities to The Legend of
Zelda from the 8 and 16-bit era and
finally onxtra is Sackboy a big
adventure this is currently on PS plus
essential right now so I'm a little
confused why it's here too my guess is
another game was removed from essential
and Sackboy stepped up to fill the Gap
anyway this 3D platformer is amazing
especially with friends as you battle to
be the first person across the Finishing
Line with many games added there are
also a few leaving seven in fact which
will be going away on April 18th they
are Naruto Shippuden Ultimate Ninja
Storm 4 Marvel Puzzle Quest dark Reign
gabuchi too dark the wonderful 101
remastered croiler Sigma and the
Caligula effect overdose and there's
worse news because here in the UK and EU
we are losing three more games Steins
Gate Elite zanky zero last beginning and
428 Shibuya scramble okay let's move on
to PS Plus premium the additional free
games to add even more to your
collection this month it's almost
totally dedicated to doom and I mean
that there's the original Doom from
1993. it's here there's Doom 2 from
1995. yep it's here too there's Doom 64
the exclusive Nintendo game and to top
it all off there is doom 3. doom 3 was
the reimagining of the original game
with an easier story to grasp about
hell's mightiest Warrior coming to town
and by the way this includes all the
DLCs that came with the games and
finally game number 17 if you're still
here Dishonored Definitive Edition on
the PS4 a masterpiece of a game from
2012. it could be played as stealthy as
you'd like or as loud and gun blazing as
possible our job is to assassinate
targets by any means necessary with
multiple ways to get the job done but as
the story progresses we develop new
supernatural abilities that change
everything Dishonored won so many games
of the Year Awards in 2012 and you
definitely try it and that is our month
April is done and dusted I'm going for a
lay down thank you for your time it's
been a pleasure see ya